me is always seeking union
that's literally the purpose of creation
the very purpose of creation is to
undergo
this dreamed evolutionary ascent
where the self-awareness
goes from a place of being
veiled by its forgetfulness
of its true nature
and going through a seeking process to
pierce that veil in
to union with its true nature
so part of intelligent infinity
uses the mechanism
of this
electromagnetic field
architected universe that
appears as a space time that appears
as planets orbiting stars that have
evolved
life from single cell to civilization
and then those self-aware individuated
mind body spirit complexes going through
a process
of seeking externally
for peace and happiness and union with
material objects or relationships or
substances
or experiences then they
get hit by the
drill sergeant of awakening which is
suffering with a big sledgehammer
which catalyzes that turn inward like in
the parable of the prodigal son
and then they find like rumi said that
diamond necklace that was already there
the whole time
and so they taste that union
of that infinite conscious nature
the absolute unbounded nature
the unified field nature and then they
go through a process of purifying
those last bits of conditioning
and then that is
how this expression of intelligent
infinity
is architected
and there are infinite
other possibilities for expressions of
intelligent infinity
to undergo this dreamed
ascensionary process of piercing through
a veil of forgetting
and awakening uniting with true nature